hi I'm Matt Welsh editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and author of McCain the
myth of a maverick we're outside the
excel centre on the final day of the
republican national convention here in
st. Paul where John McCain is going to
for one last time make his case to the
American people think you're going to
see a significant tonal difference from
last night when you had Mitt Romney
railing against liberals in getting the
crowd chanting along and other people
leading a zero chance against Barack
Obama McCain has a problem this year and
that problem is the republican party the
Republican Party is losing market share
and many would argue deservedly so for
its performance in the federal
government over the last eight years a
performance for which they have not
spent much time offering maiya culpas to
the American people including growing
government which they keep accusing the
Democrats of wanting to do and doing
themselves but what McCain needs to do
is reach out to people who don't like
the Republican Party anymore and don't
belong to it anymore if they ever did
the way that he's going to do that is
not necessarily by talking about the
areas of public disagreement beyond the
Iraq war which they will talk about but
he's going to talk about himself as a
great man as someone who has made hard
decisions who you know didn't accept
early release from a Vietnam prison cell
he's going to offer the great man theory
of politics which will by its very
definition involved the least amount of
ideas about how one actually governs
which is an important way for McCain to
get his message across but it's rather
frightening for those of us who know his
ideas which are in almost every instance
interventionist whether militarily
abroad or at home with domestic economic
policy for recent TV I am Matt Welch
you